this is the birthplace of the Internet
let's enter this very special place that
machine over there is the first piece of
Internet equipment this is a military
hardened machine it has a unique odor
and it was from here that the first
message was sent a revolution began I do
not really recall what my first
experience with the internet was you
have to know you're dealing with a man
who has made his first phone call at the
age of 17
this here is robot 8 it's very
identifiable because it's pattern
includes 4 green dots on top and it's
it's one of our favorites actually
beautiful do you love it yes we do love
robot it my name is van Hartzog I'm a
filmmaker and I'm showing low and behold
reveries of the connected world it's a
film about the internet exploring what a
humanistic side of what's going on with
us with a revolution that we are
undergoing right now the Internet is a
manifestation of evil itself
I think we have to find some sort of a
balance how we are using the Internet
but we should not demonize it of course
it shows all the dark side cyberbullying
and addiction to the Internet but at the
same time it has given us glorious
glorious moments in science Elon Musk
the founder of SpaceX is pursuing how we
would talk to colonies on Mars via the
Internet
I mean right now we can't even get one
person to Mars so clearly I would come
along I wouldn't have a problem the
Internet is a gigantic step in in our
civilization at least as large as for
example introduction of electricity
we're going to have a revolution in our
definition of what it means to be human
well our children's children's children
need the companionship of humans or will
they have evolved in a world where
that's not important I'm not a prophet
but I know that it's all pervasive and
it's a huge huge huge momentous event
and we have to learn how to cope with it
prudently have the monks stopped
meditating they all seem to be tweeting